hello and welcome to this video playing
plus no way so we had an English opening
oops what are you doing to me so um
should be four is normally the way to
try to make this work let's just develop
him even kids look like a deja vu like I
had this on the board and it wasn't all
that clear even though it looks terrible
at first good luck the iaaf I had this I
had this on the board each five and so
honest is coming rather quickly hmm I
should have played an early d3 and I
probably said the same thing the first
time I had this on the on the board
sorry
okay let's sacrifice the poor Nia to get
an open B file and I want to sit around
and wait until he places age 5 inch for
stuff it will calm I mean absolutely for
sure um so there should be six quincy to
at least and I'm attacking your form
okay I don't know if this is this pants
leg was any good I was I just didn't
want to sit around doing nothing
probably should just play in early d3 at
some point but ribbon six is still a
decent move but ok can't do all kinds of
things even even maybe just take on c3 I
don't think this is particularly bad
even though it's fair well it helps
white him takes pawn takes I'm ready for
Bishop f4 and push should be three and
so on
now it's probably a better movement to
take it tends to do it and I did
I like a tempo here somehow I would like
to place he forward we should be true or
should be three but I have a nekkid
tempo now let's do this then what a
weird game I think I was cool to see
opening up almost in the same way
earlier like some weeks ago
now maybe he allows me to play Bishop
tutu for at least activate stuff yeah
let's put it here maybe I can take f-16
you form
yeah probably an early t3 bishop t2 is
good somehow what she does here is the
same thing is no one with colors
reviewers but a tempo up should really
be good but didn't do it so what is plus
going to do maybe bring the Queen over
to the kingside something Queen a six
maybe to attack e to all these moves
look somewhat somebody logical
[Music]
gained some space on the queenside
this is not threatening much but okay so
yeah do i take i don't i don't think i
should this be Bishop f4 is it's too
interesting here too to give up so
prevented this threatening a 6 not like
winning but at least I'm stirring up
some trouble and c4 is interesting in
this position Queen cheeks
that's interesting Queen oh wow but I
didn't consider but ok so i just need
need the Bishop f4 a choice got age 6 ok
I could put the Queen to a three at xe5
again I can actually go here temple and
again temple so defended this Bishop age
three it's not the size of it all I
don't know I would love to get the
bishop on that day in a little bit I
don't know if I can manage maybe bring
it to c3 sit sir it's not easy to play
this him
[Music]
huh Wow time morning that looks very
dangerous or like if you ask me you
probably do ask me so take take that in
69 yes this is possible hmm yes Queen 33
check unfortunately I still probably
have to do it a green check isn't all
that big a deal oh ok what's the danger
is that dangerous I don't know
I don't know 24 I think was a bit of an
unlucky decision now I'm breaking
through him check despite check black
forfeits on time I still am so kind of
upset about the opening that then I got
into this trouble again really so how
should I do this not not that I'm I
should not I'm not expecting to do to
win or something but I should not be in
any trouble I should probably start with
d3s the end you suggest here this is
getting really think this is just
annoying why have to go d 3m i mean III
castles long and we should be five
something like that put pressure i have
to go up with an early III is it really
shouldn't be that i have to suck porn
and play for something something fishy I
mean the computer has given me a bit of
compensation like this is it's not a
deep calculation of course but um yeah
he was okay for a very long time
certainly I mean here if he takes it
taking I wanted to go couldn't be true
actually isn't that interesting Miami
checking here and here today for me
three so camp disposal all massively
unclear no Luke JC to would have killed
him
hmm you know I cannot take this because
of made okay check and tik I could have
taken immediately of course check check
he just just about holds at him Oh
rookie to was made huh okay yeah
probably he doesn't manage this in two
seconds but whoa ya next time really
played III okay thanks for watching